but we begin with a number of
fast-moving developments in the Russia
probe house Intel committee member Tom
Rooney told Fox News today that the
Russia investigation has become a dead
end after testimony by White House aide
hope Hicks well that's what President
Trump has been insisting with no
evidence of collusion having been
emerged and now there are new charges
from Devon Nunez that the FBI may have
violated federal law in seeking that
FISA warrant for Carter page and there
may be more indictments coming from the
Muller team of more Russians this time
for the hacking to get into it all let's
bring in former deputy Independent
Counsel Saul Eisenberg San Francisco
attorney and RNC committee woman from
California Harmeet Dillon and Washington
attorney and chair of the DC Democratic
Party Scott Bolden it's great to see all
of you we got a lot of news to get
through tonight a Tom Rooney who's on
the house Intel committee he's I think
he's given one interview about the probe
yet but he said today on the House
Intelligence of that and he said you
know this thing should we should we
should end this thing I'm the mother
thing he said well that has to keep
going I'm not gonna speak to that but he
was really adamant Saul given what we
know now what the focus is of this
investigation what are the key points
well the key points are waiting for Bob
Muller and and we just don't know what
he's doing he's kept a very tight tight
ship over there I'm not at all surprised
by the report of the committee member
and also you have to remember however a
lot of the people who have gone in to
testify have have refused to do so but
they don't have the power anywhere near
the power that Bob Muller has now having
said that what we do know publicly right
now including what people have said
about how there were questioned by
Muller is that we still don't have on
the public record any evidence of
collusion by
Trump are people closely affiliated with
Trump that's just the way it is you have
you have a little bit of stuff about
Papadopoulos but he's a very minor
figure
now let's get to Andrew McCabe Scott
let's go to you on this Andrew McCain
former deputy director the FBI is now it
looks like the IG is going to come down
on him hard because he directed FBI
staff to share information about the
ongoing investigation October 2016 with
the media well he may have it he may
have shared it himself I mean they
wanted to get some information out to
the New York Times and they they
actually set it up the PR people at the
FBI if you made a bad judgment call and
he used that information that was
confidential when he shared it to kind
of balance out the article then
certainly he's gonna be disciplined but
the reality is Andrew McCabe is a
Republican 1 and 2 in that article he
was argument for the FBI to continue to
investigate HRC and as a result there's
a dispute about that one there in there
to say that well there are two different
accounts I think the New York Times lays
it out two different accounts some say
he actually wanted hit the Hillary
investigation not to go forward and then
his having kids champion say oh no no he
said FBI you can do whatever you want
but senior Justice Department officials
disagreed those are diametrically
opposed position so facts don't lie
they don't go obsessed with dwell well
in harm and I think you'll want to chime
in on this Andrew McCabe is best buds
with Jim call me okay very good very
good and today was a crime Scott but he
was the lead in the Hillary email
investigation and then took a lead in
the Trump investigation that's the
problem and if you're pushing stories to
The Wall Street Journal in October 2016
in addition to the concerns about his
wife and everything else
you can't blame Donald Trump to thinking
this guy should never have been touch in
my case get even just given his wife's
connection to Terry McAuliffe
harmie yeah no absolutely Laura what we
were seeing here is just one more
brushstroke in a painting and
these strokes are coming together to
show that there was an entire culture at
the FBI and even you know some of the
actions that they've taken with regard
to the FISA Court that show a complete
lack of regard for the normal conflict
of interest rules for the normal ethics
that would apply these are people who
have been making false representations
to a court and so nothing that's coming
out here with regard to mccabe or any of
these other players is surprising to me
it's just surprising that that they're
being allowed to get away with it and
distract all of us from what should be
going on what the president should be
focusing on in the country moving
forward and they've been successful in
bogging him down so that's the
disappointing part of this a Ken Starr
saw today made an interesting comment
about the scope of this investigation
we're hearing stuff about Jared Kushner
we're hearing things about Ivanka Trump
now this is what he said I think it's
beyond his mandate the mandate is what
happened during the 2016 election in
terms of collusion that's the key idea
so here's what I think is happening I
think Bob Mahler is finding out
information that is leading him back to
the Japanese Ernie general saw your
comments on that well there's no
question that it sits outside the
mandate in terms of the specific items
covered but remember the mandate says if
there's anything any crime that directly
arises from the investigation he can
look at it but we know from rod Rhodes
and science testimony that he's got to
go to rod Rosenstein if any of those
things occur and he's got to get the
agreement of Rosenstein so the real
story here I don't think there's any
doubt he would have gotten authorization
the story is we know from the Manafort
indictment and the gates indictment all
you have to do is look at it that he got
authorization long ago to go beyond the
four corners at least these specific
things he's supposed to be looking at
and I'm surprised it hadn't you know
been commented on that much earlier if I
could go back for one minute to McCabe
the two that to me the two main things
about McCabe that we have to keep going
back to one the gross conflict of
interest he should not have been
neither the email or the Clinton
Foundation investigation which if you
believe news reports he kept agents from
looking at things and number two he is
responsible for that FISA warrant and
that FISA warrant he is admitted and and
shift the shift memo did not contradict
this that if they had not had steeled
the steel dossier they would not have
even submitted that and that that's a
shocking thing that's a shocking and in
the Devon Nunez letter today Scott where
he went into chapter and verse about the
DOJ guidelines he's in in part the
accuracy of information contained within
FISA applications is of utmost
importance only documented and verified
information may be used to support FBI
applications FISA to the FISA Court they
did not verify the outrageous
allegations in this dossier and they
couldn't there was no way for them to
this yet that was at the core of this
application was a federal statute
violated in their submission of this
certainly never know that but it seems
to me the fundamental difference between
the Democrats and Republicans obviously
is the Republicans think it was the
heart of that FISA warrant and the
Democrats think it was part of it we
know back in September of 2016 that the
Intel agencies were picking up these
communications and we're doing their own
investigation you can you mean if you
didn't verify everything in the FISA
more if you didn't document everything
that means there were other things in
that FISA warrant that told you that the
Trump administration or the campaign
needed to be investigated and by the way
there's a term call corroboration that
solid knows very well if everything and
f5s want was corroborated then what are
we talking about then I mean you make a
big deal out of bits this FISA war but
they went back to the files and judges
well of course they are and what does he
have to do with and it says has a very
high floor judges do it over and over
because why because they weren't told
and paid for the DA say they
were and even they did rarities no way
oh oh do you don't know that let's just
give down a breast caulking job or hard
part do you think that a federal judge
on the FISA Court if he knew what
happened with this dossier and who paid
for it that they would have not at least
gone back to the lore set is this all
you have do you have any anything else
because this seems like a direct
conflict of interest I mean go ahead saw
they were they would have absolutely
asked further questions now Scott makes
one fair point when they go good three
times not just fair point good point
I'll be fair if you let me if you let me
compliment you when they do go back
three times they have to have some kind
of new information about page but it
doesn't change and we don't know what
that is but it doesn't change the fact
and this is what people aren't picking
up on with exception of a couple of
writers like Andrew McCarthy Steele
himself could have been the most
credible person in the world but almost
all of his information was completely I
mean completely unverified that's
shocking and actually that's something
the FISA judges should have to answer
for someday or explain I'd like to hear
about that Harold Stassen I know it I
don't care what their political
affiliation is Harmeet last word yeah I
know I was going to agree that you know
the misrepresentations to the FISA Court
cannot be minimized here they're
critical and central to the issuance of
this warrant every single time and that
leads to questions about the FISA whole
situation and whether it's open to
abuses like this but the other thing I
think is important is what Devon Nunez
has said in his letter today it's not
just relying to the FISA Court but it is
obstruction of justice
it is conspiracy to violate the rights
of American citizens a series of
violations that he say are says their
potential I think the one that's pretty
obvious is the the guidelines I think
they didn't verify the claims in that
dossier phenomenal panel and I can't
believe Saul complement complement it
Scott that is that that's never happened
once almost you know okay it's all
smiled at least three times in this
segment and harmie does well so as long
ago